[Music]
[Music]
are you okay
what is it your heart are you having
trouble breathing
[Music]
did you hear that actually i did hear
something okay there's someone out there
i'm gonna get my gun okay tom scare him
off and shoot over his head what's that
gonna do i'm gonna shoot under its head
whoa
don't shoot anyone
what do you do
hey it's craig from from ronald mercedes
craig craig i got you tom craig don't
worry i'm coming listen i heard about
the accident and i need to know who is
responsible uh i don't know
that's the problem i am
i shot ron swanson you shot my mercedes
what no no
is this everybody ann took a cab tom's
in the trunk jerry's on the roof
all right where to first
your mother's butt
i'm so alone
if even one of you thinks about dry
heaven in my car you're all walking home
there's no vans within 50 miles and for
some reason no one wants to lend me 10
000
even if we had the dough that bunko
artist would just demand more trust me
don't move let's just stay here for like
an hour and not let him out this isn't
right our girls worked hard we're so
close
i know he didn't just hit my baby hey
what the hell guys
move
all right
y'all got your seatbelt
done did you see that that son of a
[ __ ] just rear-ended me
am i dead
what the hell
exactly bill
what the hell
you just rear-ended me that is not what
happened but i got witnesses yeah it
went down exactly the way my girl said
it did you mean bald man
hey what about you mr uh a man's word is
sacred well it is but you're an ass
so we can settle this now i will accept
payment and van rentals
okay donna where do you want this uh-uh
that's it
my baby has a delicate suspension
are you kidding me no i'm not move
putting your truck right in which
there's plenty of room
five pocket squares
crank it hit it you need 16 minutes for
premium bounce
oh hey after this can you go pick up
freddy spaghetti and your mercedes we
need to give him the star treatment so
while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking i'm not street parking my
mercedes well everyone is i'm doing it
cause nobody wants to steal a saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
they put up a fence
whoo
no what's that there's a small park on
the line between pawnee and eagleton and
last night
eagleton put up a fence around their
side to keep us disgusting pawnee hobos
off their precious land there's even a
security guard you got to show eagleton
id to get in eagleton is a bunch of rich
snobs and that's coming from someone who
has a mercedes with the harden carmen
logic 7 surround sound system
oh lord
is he eating soup on a bench alone
tom
fine on rubber band
come with us what are you no arguing for
no super events you didn't what
what
what is happening right now
your campaign advisors quit big deal
you're running for city council again
leslie with our help
april ludgate
youth outreach and director of new media
tom haverford image consultant swagger
coach
ann perkins office manager and volunteer
coordinator
andy dwyer security sweets
body man
javelin if need be donna meagle transpo
aka rides in my bins
you